any presidential appointment has the
power to change the course and
trajectory of the University but I would
venture to say that Carnegie Mellon is
lively history no presidency has been
more important than the one we are about
to enter and really for the best reasons
and now let me take one step into the
future it introduces you the 10th
president of Carnegie Mellon University
Farnum Johnny Farnham to honey and
possesses a rare set of qualities and
experiences that make him exactly the
right leader for this university and
this extraordinary moment and to the
extent that you know Farnum
you know that his heart is in the work
he dedicated our work to finding a
president who would value our unique
culture of innovation and collaboration
leading us to build on the potential of
this moment in our history
to accept this appointment as the next
president of this great institution in
this fantastically vibrant city so today
I stand here as a true believer in the
power of higher education I am in awe of
all that you have to offer and your
dedication to making the world smarter
safer more equitable and more inspiring
I am looking forward to hearing your
dreams for shaping the world and the
future of this great institution now
let's get to work
thank you very much